This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In February of 2021, at around 9.40 pm, Ryan Fisher was taking a lovely evening stroll down Sunset Boulevard in Los Angeles. Fisher, a self-described nanny to a frenzy of Frenchies, had three French bulldogs in tow as he turned onto a residential street. Suddenly, a white sedan pulled up next to him and two men sprang out of the vehicle. They were armed and they demanded that he hand over the dogs immediately. That is journalist Tova Denovich.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2021年2月晚上9点40分左右，瑞安·费舍尔正在洛杉矶日落大道上悠闲地散步。费舍尔自称是“法斗狂热保姆”，当时他牵着三只法国斗牛犬转入了一条住宅街道。突然，一辆白色轿车停在他身边，两名男子从车里跳了出来。他们持有武器，要求他立即交出狗。这就是记者托娃·德诺维奇。
Brain Fisher did not hand over the dogs and as a result he was shot once in the chest. Gunshots were heard, two of them. The victim falls back as the assailants race back to the car with the two dogs. And the attackers fled with two of the three Frenches who were named Koji and Gustav. Fisher luckily survived the shooting, but this dog-napping triggered a wave of media attention because Koji and Gustav weren't just any Frenches. They were Lady Gaga's Frenches. Friends of the man who was shot tell us he was constantly walking Lady Gaga's dogs in this
布莱恩·费舍尔没有交出狗，结果胸部中了一枪。人们听到了两声枪响。受害者向后倒下，袭击者带着两只狗冲回车里。袭击者带着三只法斗中的两只逃跑了，它们的名字叫科吉和古斯塔夫。幸运的是，费舍尔在枪击中幸存下来，但这次“绑架狗”事件引发了媒体的广泛关注，因为科吉和古斯塔夫可不是普通的法斗。它们是Lady Gaga的法斗。被枪击男子的朋友告诉我们，他经常在这个
neighborhood, and he doesn't know what that was. Due to their celebrity owner, a lot of people assumed the dogs were stolen to collect a ransom from Lady Gaga. She did in fact offer a $500,000 reward for their return, which is a lot of money. Yeah, that is a lot of money. But the truth is, if anyone had been walking down this road in Los Angeles with Frenchies, at the time that this dog
街区遛Lady Gaga的狗，他不知道发生了什么。由于它们的名人主人，许多人认为这些狗被偷是为了向Lady Gaga勒索赎金。她确实为找回它们提供了50万美元的悬赏，这可是一大笔钱。是的，那确实是一大笔钱。但事实是，如果当时有任何人在洛杉矶这条路上遛法斗，
walker was, those dogs would have been targeted. This whole fiasco had nothing to do with Lady Gaga. It was just a crime of opportunity. Because at the end of the day, dogs aren't just pets. They're commodities. And while this particular case got a huge amount of media attention, French bulldog theft is actually extremely common. Frenchies can cost anywhere from $3,000 to $9,000. And some with rare colored coat patterns go for up to $20,000. The average take in a bank robbery,
就像这位遛狗人一样，这些狗也会成为目标。整场闹剧与Lady Gaga毫无关系。这只是一起机会犯罪。因为归根结底，狗不仅仅是宠物。它们是商品。虽然这个特定案例获得了巨大的媒体关注，但法国斗牛犬盗窃案实际上非常普遍。法斗的价格从3000美元到9000美元不等。一些毛色罕见的甚至能卖到2万美元。顺便说一句，根据联邦调查局的数据，
by the way, according to the FBI, is $6,500. I'd wager that stealing someone's French bulldog off the street is significantly easier than robbing a bank. $15,000 worth of French bulldog is a pretty good day, I would say. There is a huge demand for French bulldogsdogs because these dogs are selectively bred and designed with human needs in mind. Frenches are marketed as easy and friendly, perfect for millennial workers on the go. They don't bark much or shed, they barely need walks.
银行抢劫案的平均收益是6500美元。我敢打赌，在街上偷走某人的法国斗牛犬比抢劫银行要容易得多。价值1.5万美元的法国斗牛犬，可以说是一个相当不错的收获。人们对法国斗牛犬的需求巨大，因为这些狗是经过选择性繁育的，是根据人类的需求而设计的。法斗被营销为简单友好，非常适合忙碌的千禧一代上班族。它们不怎么叫，也不怎么掉毛，几乎不需要遛。
They're the second most popular dog breed in America today, presumably because they don't have many of the needs or demands of regular dogs. But how did we get here to this point where we've tried to breed the dog out of dogs? Tova Denevich wrote a great essay about the history of purebred dogs for Vox, and she says it oddly enough to understand the modern obsession with purebred dogs like the Franchi, you actually have to start with chickens.
它们是当今美国第二受欢迎的犬种，大概是因为它们没有普通狗的许多需求或要求。但我们是如何走到这一步的，试图通过繁育来消除狗的“狗性”？托娃·德诺维奇为Vox写了一篇关于纯种狗历史的精彩文章，她说，奇怪的是，要理解现代人对像法斗这样的纯种狗的痴迷，你实际上必须从鸡开始说起。
Victorian era chickens. Someone brought Queen Victoria some extremely fancy chickens. And soon after receiving these very bougie chickens, the Queen became obsessed with owning poultry, which eventually meant everyone became obsessed with owning poultry. Victorians never met a fad they didn't like, so. It became an international craze. These chickens would go for the equivalent of thousands of dollars
维多利亚时代的鸡。有人送给维多利亚女王一些极其华丽的鸡。在收到这些非常时髦的鸡之后，女王很快就迷上了养禽类，这最终意味着每个人都迷上了养禽类。维多利亚时代的人从不拒绝任何潮流，所以这成了一种国际狂热。这些鸡的价格相当于数千美元，
and would be exhibited at poultry shows. They called it hen fever. And it was because of all of these livestock shows and chicken shows that people were like, you know what, we should also show dogs. And you know, usually show that my dog is better than the dog that you have bred specifically. But how can you tell if my dog is better than your dog?
并且会在家禽展上展出。他们称之为“母鸡热”。正是因为所有这些牲畜展和鸡展，人们才觉得，你知道吗，我们也应该展示狗。而且你知道，通常是为了展示我的狗比你专门繁育的狗更好。但你怎么能判断我的狗比你的狗好呢？
Today, we'd compare breeds. But before the Victorian era, the term breed didn't actually exist. Instead, people use words like strain or variety to describe different types of dogs. They were grouped according to the work they did, hurting and protecting, hunting and retrieving, pointing, guarding, sniffing. And until the Victorian time, when we looked at dogs, we really looked at what purpose
今天，我们会比较品种。但在维多利亚时代之前，“品种”这个词实际上并不存在。相反，人们使用“品系”或“变种”之类的词来描述不同类型的狗。它们是根据它们所做的工作进行分组的：牧羊和保护、狩猎和寻回、定点指示、守卫、嗅探。直到维多利亚时代，当我们看狗时，我们真正看重的是它们所服务的目的。
did they serve. And the dog that served that purpose could look like just any number of different things. It didn't really matter. Meaning, there wasn't any concept of different things, it didn't really matter. Meaning there wasn't any concept of categorizing a dog based on what it looked like. It was all based around what it could do. Any dog that was good at fetching things was retriever. It didn't matter if it was baker's small, slobbery, or hairless. And then, in 1860, dog shows started popping up in England, and they were meant to determine
而服务于该目的的狗可以有各种各样的外表。这并不重要。意思是，当时没有任何基于外表对狗进行分类的概念。一切都基于它们能做什么。任何擅长取物的狗都是寻回犬。它长得是胖是瘦、流不流口水或有没有毛都不重要。然后，在1860年，狗展开始在英国出现，它们旨在确定
the best dog. But of course, it's really hard to prove my dog is the best at retrieving. My dog is really good at finding rats in small holes. Skills like sniffing or retrieving are all kind of relative and hard to judge in competition. So instead of that really kind of subjective way of going about things, they're like, you know, we'll make a standard that says a terrier should be 16 inches high, have this color fur, a tail that looks like this, this approximate body shape, because this is really easy to judge.
最好的狗。但当然，很难证明我的狗在寻回方面是最好的。我的狗非常擅长在小洞里找老鼠。嗅探或寻回等技能在某种程度上都是相对的，很难在比赛中评判。所以，与其用那种非常主观的方式，他们说，你知道，我们会制定一个标准，规定梗犬应该有16英寸高，有这种颜色的毛，尾巴看起来像这样，大致是这种体型，因为这非常容易评判。
A dog show was essentially a dog beauty contest with very strict guidelines. Judging was entirely based on a dog's visual appeal. And because of these shows, dogs started to become categorized as breeds, which was much more than just a language change. Dog breeds for something entirely new, defined by their form and not their function. The different types of dogs became like blocks on a pantone color card, each uniform and discreet. So it made it so people could compete with a wide range of dogs
狗展本质上是一场有着非常严格指导方针的狗狗选美比赛。评判完全基于狗的视觉吸引力。由于这些展览，狗开始被归类为品种，这不仅仅是语言上的改变。犬种是全新的事物，由它们的形式而非功能来定义。不同类型的狗变得像潘通色卡上的色块，每个都统一且离散。这使得人们可以用各种各样的狗来竞争，
and say, my dog is the finest of all the dogs. And that's really why that change happened. This standardization of dog breeds was driven by a group of people in England called the dog fancy. The fancy were a loose group of urban working class Englishmen who bred and sold dogs. And as you can imagine, the fancy were interested in spectacle and show, but they had a problem.
并说，我的狗是所有狗中最好的。这就是这种变化发生的原因。这种犬种的标准化是由英国一群被称为“狗迷”的人推动的。这些“狗迷”是一群松散的城市工人阶级英国人，他们繁育并出售狗。正如你可以想象的那样，他们对奇观和表演感兴趣，但他们遇到了一个问题。
The fancy felt like the judges at these dog shows were just giving the top prizes to their friends. So they came up with a kind of rubric, a standardized set of points that would determine the best dog. And for the first time ever, there were vigorous disagreements about the correct angle of an ear or the desired curl of a tail. And to develop a breed, all you really had to do was get a group of probably men together who wanted to breed dogs that all looked x-way and say, okay, we have now made the Labrador Retriever how wonderful.
这些“狗迷”觉得狗展的评委只是把最高奖项给了他们的朋友。所以他们想出了一套准则，一套标准化的评分体系来决定最好的狗。这是有史以来第一次，人们对耳朵的正确角度或尾巴的理想卷曲程度产生了激烈的争论。要开发一个品种，你真正需要做的就是召集一群可能想繁育出某种特定外貌的狗的男人，然后说，好吧，我们现在创造了拉布拉多寻回犬，太棒了。
We've all decided that it should look in the specific way, so we are going to go to the local Penal Club, apply for our dog to become a new way. So we are going to go to the local Penal Club, apply for our dog to become, you know, a new breed, and the books will be closed. Meaning once the fancy had established a certain set of characteristics, that was the definition of the breed. And what that means is if there were 30 dogs at that time that were considered Labrador Retrievers. There can never be any new Labrador Retriever added to that gene pool. And that is actually the definition of a purebred dog is that it only comes from this group of genes when the books were closed.
我们都决定它应该看起来像这样，所以我们要去当地的犬业俱乐部，申请让我们的狗成为一个新品种，然后登记册就会关闭。这意味着一旦“狗迷”确定了一组特定的特征，这就是该品种的定义。这意味着如果当时有30只狗被认为是拉布拉多寻回犬，那么该基因库中就永远不能添加任何新的拉布拉多寻回犬。这实际上就是纯种狗的定义，即它只来自登记册关闭时那组基因。
It was the dog show that really defined the dog breeds we have today. I think dog shows are really the reason for the transition from function to form. So all of the changes that we've made to dog breeds because the breed itself is a very visual standard have been aesthetic choices. Throughout history, these dog breeds have been shifting and morphing based on aesthetic standards
正是狗展真正定义了我们今天所拥有的犬种。我认为狗展确实是从功能向形式转变的原因。因此，我们对犬种所做的所有改变，因为品种本身就是一个非常视觉化的标准，都是审美选择。纵观历史，这些犬种一直在根据审美标准进行转变和演变，
that change over time. Sometimes for no good reason other than personal taste. The German Shepherd is a really great example of this because the vast majority of German shepherds today can trace their lineage back to the very first dog known as the German Shepherd, who was named Horin von Graffeth, which is fantastic. The breeders scoured different villages until they found Horin, and they bred him as the source of the original German Shepherd line, a dog breed specifically bred to her sheep. If you looked at him compared to the German shepherds that might be at Westminster dog show today, they're
这些标准随着时间的推移而改变。有时除了个人品味外，没有任何正当理由。德国牧羊犬就是一个很好的例子，因为今天绝大多数德国牧羊犬都可以追溯到第一只被称为德国牧羊犬的狗，它的名字叫霍兰·冯·格拉夫斯，这太棒了。繁育者搜寻了不同的村庄，直到找到霍兰，并将他作为原始德国牧羊犬血统的源头，这是一种专门为牧羊而繁育的犬种。如果你把他和今天威斯敏斯特狗展上的德国牧羊犬相比，它们
very, very different. That's because people's taste for what a German shepherd should look like has changed since the first German shepherd, again, I'm going to say his name, Horan von Graff-Rath, came on the scene. It became a thing in the mid-century for German shepherds to have a sloping back on them. People began selecting for a sloping back, even though it hindered, you know, herding sheep and was detrimental to the dog's health. And this was done for literally no practical reason, just because it looked cool.
非常非常不同。这是因为人们对德国牧羊犬应该长什么样的品味，自第一只德国牧羊犬——我再说一遍他的名字，霍兰·冯·格拉夫斯——出现以来已经发生了变化。在世纪中叶，德国牧羊犬背部倾斜成为了一种潮流。人们开始选择背部倾斜的，尽管这阻碍了它们牧羊，并且对狗的健康有害。这实际上没有任何实际原因，仅仅是因为它看起来很酷。
So over time, they've really changed from a dog that could herd sheep to one that, you know, maybe has trouble running because of the aesthetic choices that we've made. The governing aesthetics of dog shows trickled out to the masses, even when purebred owners never had any intention of breeding or showing dogs themselves. And over time, breeds started to rise in fall and popularity, like fads. Purebreds would become a proxy for class and social status. People started talking about how purebred dogs were, you know, really healthy and dignified and so classy and always well behaved and the dogs of the poor, those guys who even know what they're going to get up to.
所以随着时间的推移，它们确实从一种能牧羊的狗变成了一种因为我们所做的审美选择而可能跑步都有困难的狗。狗展的统治性审美渗透到了大众之中，即使纯种狗主人从来没有打算自己繁育或展示狗。随着时间的推移，品种的流行度开始起起落落，就像潮流一样。纯种狗成了阶级和社会地位的象征。人们开始谈论纯种狗是多么健康、高贵、优雅，总是表现良好，而穷人的狗，那些家伙甚至不知道它们会干出什么事来。
So that became a very, very quick class distinction. That didn't really change until after the middle of the century. The dog aids men in other ways. In time of war, his workers of a serious nature. In the post-war era, pure-bred dogs were being bred on a much larger scale, like cars, guns, and sliced bread. Dogs became another example of 20th century mass production. Today there is no question of the dogs' place in society. He goes everywhere.
所以这很快就成了一种阶级区分。这种情况直到世纪中叶之后才真正改变。狗以其他方式帮助人类。在战争时期，它是严肃性质的工作者。在战后时期，纯种狗正在大规模繁育，就像汽车、枪支和切片面包一样。狗成了20世纪大规模生产的另一个例子。今天，狗在社会中的地位毋庸置疑。它无处不在。
A lot of farmers were kind of urged to treat dogs as like a side crop. Farmers in the Midwest were facing hard times with massive crop failures. In the idea of breeding and selling purebred puppies started to seem like a fool-proof way to make some extra cash on the side. Plus, breeding dogs is much less labor intensive than what it takes to grow food. The USDA even had a program promoting them. American farmers started to pack dogs into chicken coops and rabbit huts and sell puppies to pet stores.
许多农民被敦促将狗视为一种副业作物。中西部的农民面临着严重的作物歉收。繁育和销售纯种幼犬的想法开始看起来是一种赚取额外现金的万无一失的方法。此外，繁育狗比种植食物的劳动强度要小得多。美国农业部甚至有一个推广它们的项目。美国农民开始把狗塞进鸡舍和兔笼里，并将幼犬卖给宠物店。
The supply of these pirabret dogs exploded and with this newly booming retail pet industry, a lot of middle-class families could suddenly afford a pirabret dog for the first time. But I think throughout history, we've really seen this same pattern play out where rich people did something and then people who were in a class slightly below them wanted to emulate that. That's four to a couple of decades and then we have TV and movies to help us determine which dogs we think of as cool and trendy. So once television in particular became a really big medium, we started watching these dogs to really amazing things.
这些纯种狗的供应量激增，随着这个新兴的零售宠物行业的繁荣，许多中产阶级家庭突然第一次买得起纯种狗了。但我认为纵观历史，我们确实看到了同样的模式在重演：富人做某事，然后阶级稍低的人想要效仿。这持续了几十年，然后我们有了电视和电影来帮助我们确定我们认为哪些狗是酷和时尚的。所以一旦电视成为一种非常大的媒介，我们开始看着这些狗做一些非常了不起的事情。
When I was a kid, the Itdog was the collie because of the last-e-movies and TV specials. For the generation before me, it was the German Shepherd because of Ren Tenten. When I was young dating myself, we had wishbone. So anyone with a Jack Russell Terrier was the coolest person in school. So we kind of get this idea implanted,
当我还是个孩子的时候，最流行的狗是柯利犬，因为《灵犬莱西》的电影和电视特辑。对于我之前的那一代人，它是德国牧羊犬，因为《丁丁历险记》。当我年轻时——暴露年龄了——我们有《许愿骨》。所以任何养杰克罗素梗的人都是学校里最酷的人。所以我们潜意识里植入了一种想法，
probably subconsciously, that, hey, if I get one of these dogs, maybe it will also be amazing. Remember 101 Dalmatians that Disney and Made a Movie based on the novel about 101 Dalmatians? Well, after the movie came out in the 1960s, everyone wanted a Dalmatian. And when they remade the film in the 90s. Something kind of interesting happened, which is that the same fudge occurred. People went out, bought a lot of Dalmatians, but people started noting that these Dalmatians were then winding up in animal shelters.
嘿，如果我养了其中一只狗，也许它也会很了不起。还记得迪士尼根据小说改编的《101忠狗》电影吗？好吧，电影在1960年代上映后，每个人都想要一只大麦町犬。当他们在90年代重拍这部电影时，发生了一些有趣的事情，那就是同样的狂热再次出现。人们出去买了很多大麦町犬，但人们开始注意到这些大麦町犬随后被送进了动物收容所。
Because people were buying their really cool spotted dogs. You had dogs who had much higher energy needs, then we're really appropriate for the families who are going out and cool spotted dogs. You had dogs who had much higher energy needs than were really appropriate for the families who were going out and buying these dogs. And it was a really huge problem. It's such a problem, in fact, that people tend to refer to this rise and fall in dog popularity as the Dalmatian effect. We see these cycles of it dogs going in and out of style throughout the years, certain breeds being sold and later abandoned. And today, it seems like the apotheosis of all this
因为人们买的是他们觉得很酷的斑点狗。你拥有了能量需求高得多的狗，而这些狗并不适合那些出去购买它们的家庭。这是一个非常大的问题。事实上，这个问题非常严重，以至于人们倾向于将这种狗的流行度起伏称为“大麦町效应”。我们看到这些流行犬种多年来不断进出潮流，某些品种被出售，后来又被遗弃。今天，这一切的巅峰似乎
is perhaps the French bulldog. These dogs are everywhere, which makes sense because they're so damn cute. Frenchies in particular fall into a specific kind of lifestyle that they're really great for, and there is a reason why they're specifically very popular in cities like New York, Los Angeles, San Francisco, where there are a lot of wealthy people who maybe like to travel a lot. These are dogs that are about 20 pounds. They are very small dogs, little tiny waste, giant head, big expressive eyes that kind of sit wide on their face. They have this delightful smile, big bat ears, the way they vocalize. A lot of Frenchy owners describe it as talking,
也许就是法国斗牛犬。这些狗随处可见，这很合理，因为它们太可爱了。法斗特别适合某种特定的生活方式，这就是为什么它们在纽约、洛杉矶、旧金山等城市特别受欢迎的原因，那里有很多可能喜欢经常旅行的富人。这些狗大约20磅重。它们是非常小的狗，细细的腰，巨大的头，大而富有表现力的眼睛在脸上显得很宽。它们有这种令人愉悦的微笑，大大的蝙蝠耳，它们发声的方式，许多法斗主人将其描述为说话，
because it's kind of a bit of a yodel, really, because the best way to describe it. Those indirendly large, roly-poly heads mean they usually have to be born by C-section. The tiny little ways can cause a lot of spine deformities and nerve pain because they're so disproportionate. All those cute face wrinkles can make them prone to skin infections. And their squished faces lead to a lot of breathing problems. They're not really good at exercising, so you don't have to feel bad for not taking them on long walks to the specially in the hot day. It's really not good for them.
因为那听起来有点像约德尔唱法，真的是最好的描述方式。那些大得离谱的圆滚滚的脑袋意味着它们通常必须通过剖腹产出生。细小的腰部会导致许多脊柱畸形和神经痛，因为它们太不成比例了。所有那些可爱的面部皱纹使它们容易患皮肤感染。它们被挤压的脸导致了许多呼吸问题。它们不太擅长运动，所以你不必因为没有带它们进行长距离散步而感到难过，特别是在炎热的天气里。这对它们真的不好。
So yeah, they're these cute little monstrosities of nature that because of all of these characteristics that have been bred into them, they're often really sick dogs. In a way, we are still breeding dogs for a purpose, like we were before the Victorians, but the purpose has changed. It's not hurting or hunting. It's to fit into the modern world. Breeders will first sell you the idea of an easy dog on that's hypoallergenic or small enough for your purse, and then the industry will sell you the stuff to go along with it, the timed feeders and waterfounts,
所以是的，它们是这些可爱的小自然怪物，因为所有这些被繁育出来的特征，它们往往是非常多病的狗。在某种程度上，我们仍然像维多利亚时代之前那样为了某种目的繁育狗，但目的已经改变了。不是为了牧羊或狩猎。而是为了适应现代世界。繁育者会首先向你推销一种“简单”的狗，比如低过敏性或小到可以放进你的包里，然后这个行业会向你推销与之配套的东西，定时喂食器和饮水机，
the motorized doggy doors for dogs to go in and out by themselves and pee on little patches of fake grass. But it's gotten to the point where, as Tova says, we've broken the dog to accommodate us. After a century of breeding dogs for looks and not for health or talent, a study in the 90s found that a quarter of all dog breeds recognized by the American Kennel Club suffered at least one genetic disorder.
自动狗门，让狗可以自己进出并在小块假草皮上撒尿。但情况已经到了托娃所说的地步，我们为了适应我们而“破坏”了狗。在经过一个世纪为了外表而非健康或天赋繁育狗之后，90年代的一项研究发现，美国犬业俱乐部认可的所有犬种中，有四分之一至少患有一种遗传疾病。
The long list of degenerative conditions goes from German shepherds with bad hips to bull terriers that can spend 80% of their time uncontrollably chasing their own tails. Golden sheavers, for example, 60% of them get cancer, which is a huge issue. And I think a lot of people getting that dog's, you know, that's not on the brochure when you're going to buy your dog. And it's, I think a lot of people would still get them and love them anyway, but I think it's really horrible to set people up without the information of this thing that they're buying into. But again, it's a matter of
长长的退行性疾病名单从髋关节不好的德国牧羊犬到可以花80%的时间无法控制地追逐自己尾巴的牛头梗。例如，60%的金毛寻回犬会患癌症，这是一个巨大的问题。我认为很多买狗的人，你知道，当你去买狗时，宣传册上并没有写这些。我认为很多人仍然会买它们并爱它们，但我认为在不告知人们所购买的东西的情况下让他们承担这些后果真的很糟糕。但同样，这是一个
priorities. And getting rid of encephalitis and pugs and preserving the pugs' cute, squish nose can be to conflicting priorities. Genesis discovered that the mutation contributing to widespread deafness and Dalmatians is the exact same mutation that creates its signature spots, about 30% of Dalmatians end up losing their hearing. But will people who want Dalmatians abide a Dalmatian without spots? They're mongrels, no spots! No spots at all! What horrible little white rats!
优先级的问题。消除巴哥犬的脑炎和保持巴哥犬可爱的扁鼻子可能是相互冲突的优先级。遗传学家发现，导致大麦町犬普遍耳聋的突变与产生其标志性斑点的突变完全相同，约30%的大麦町犬最终会失去听力。但那些想要大麦町犬的人会容忍没有斑点的大麦町犬吗？它们是杂种，没有斑点！一点斑点都没有！多么可怕的小白鼠！
There's a reason why we as humans obsess over breeds. We don't have a lot of information available to us when we have to decide which dog to get. So we categorize dogs into breeds because it gives us a sense of predictability and control. We're always putting you know people, things, feelings into categories. It's a lot easier for us to understand the world in categories. And when you're getting a dog, you have this for the dog's lifetime commitment of this creature from another species
我们人类痴迷于品种是有原因的。当我们必须决定养哪种狗时，我们没有太多信息。所以我们将狗归类为品种，因为它给了我们一种可预测性和控制感。我们总是把人、事物、感觉归类。用类别来理解世界对我们来说容易得多。当你养狗时，你对这个来自另一个物种的生物有着终身的承诺，
that you can't talk to that you're bringing in your house. And in an ideal world, maybe you would like take some time to get to know each other first. But typically you have to decide, I'm gonna get this dog, or I'm gonna leave this dog behind within, you know, 30 minutes minutes maybe when you meet them. And that's really tough.
你无法与它交谈，你把它带进了你的房子。在理想的情况下，也许你会想花点时间先了解一下彼此。但通常你必须在见到它们后的30分钟内决定：我要养这只狗，或者我要放弃这只狗。这真的很艰难。
And sure, your friendship may be cute and apartment friendly, like the brochure said. But of course not every French bulldog will be as advertised, and not every owner is prepared for all the health issues that might come up over time. I think there are some people who are just not set up for even the most easy-going dog in the world. There are a lot of people who should maybe get an old dog and not a puppy. And I think until we start talking about what breeds can and cannot guarantee, that's going to keep being a problem. There's a breeder in the Netherlands, Shantal Van Cruining, who is experimenting with breeding
当然，你的法斗可能很可爱，适合公寓生活，就像宣传册上说的那样。但当然，并非每只法国斗牛犬都会像广告中那样，也不是每个主人都准备好应对随着时间推移可能出现的所有健康问题。我认为有些人甚至连最随和的狗都养不好。有很多人也许应该养一只老狗而不是幼犬。我认为在我们开始讨论品种能保证什么和不能保证什么之前，这个问题将持续存在。荷兰有一位繁育者，尚塔尔·范·克鲁宁，她正在尝试繁育
a new kind of Frenchie. She's reshaping the French bulldogs' smushed face to try to make it healthier. Chantal's Frenchies have all the characteristics people love about these dogs, but they look distinctly different. They have a much longer neck and a longer nose. These new Frenchies would hopefully have less genetic abnormalities. These dogs wouldn't be accepted as fringies by the American Kennel Club, and they couldn't compete at dog shows. But to the average consumer, it would hopefully mean their dogs can live longer.
一种新的法斗。她正在重塑法国斗牛犬被挤压的脸，试图让它更健康。尚塔尔的法斗拥有人们喜爱这些狗的所有特征，但它们看起来明显不同。它们有更长的脖子和更长的鼻子。这些新的法斗有望减少遗传异常。这些狗不会被美国犬业俱乐部接受为法斗，也不能参加狗展。但对于普通消费者来说，这意味着他们的狗有望活得更久。
From a consumer standpoint, I think people would be a lot happier with it, but it kind of goes against like the ethos of what the purebred dog is. Or maybe we should move on from the idea of breeds and think about dogs the way we did before Queen Victoria got those fancy chickens. The best thing to do is until look at dog breeds, but to actually return to those groups like the Herding Group, Terrier Group. Because if you look within there, the traits do tend to be a little bit more accurate. You can kind of see, okay, does a Terrier really fit my lifestyle when I have this beautiful garden and, you know, a fence
从消费者的角度来看，我认为人们会对此感到高兴得多，但这有点违背了纯种狗的精神。或者也许我们应该放弃品种的概念，像维多利亚女王得到那些华丽的鸡之前那样看待狗。最好的做法不是看犬种，而是真正回归到那些群体，比如牧羊犬组、梗犬组。因为如果你看看里面，特征往往会更准确一些。你可以看出，好吧，当我有一个美丽的花园和，你知道，一个
that's very easy to dig under? And that's going to tell you a lot more than any specific dog within that. We could just go back to classifying dogs by what they could do as dogs. There'd still be some sense of the predictability that we crave. It just wouldn't be based on looks. I don't know if it's what I see as the future of pure bread and designer dogs here,
很容易挖洞钻过去的栅栏时，梗犬真的适合我的生活方式吗？这会告诉你比任何特定品种更多的信息。我们可以回到根据狗能做什么来对它们进行分类。我们所渴望的可预测性仍然会存在。它只是不会基于外表。我不知道这是否是我所看到的纯种狗和设计师犬的未来，
but I would really like for that to happen. I think that we should not be reading to a standard that necessitates the dog be unhealthy. That seems like a pretty easy shift to make from where I'm standing. The other easy shift is just to go to your local shelter and adopt a mutt because pure bread or not, they're all good dogs. After the break, the creator of the Labradoodle says, breeding this dog is his life's regret.
但我真的希望这种情况发生。我认为我们不应该为了一个标准而繁育，导致狗变得不健康。从我的角度来看，这是一个很容易做出的改变。另一个简单的改变就是去你当地的收容所领养一只杂种狗，因为无论是否纯种，它们都是好狗。休息之后，拉布拉多贵宾犬的创造者说，繁育这种狗是他一生的遗憾。
After this. Bugle, cockapoo, schnoodle, yorkipoo. I'm sure you've come across these dogs before. Dogs that are hybrid breeds made from two peer breads squished together with a cutesy portmanteau. These dogs are often called designer dogs, and perhaps the most notorious of all designer dogs is the Labritudele.
广告之后。比格犬、可卡贵宾犬、雪纳瑞贵宾犬、约克夏贵宾犬。我相信你以前见过这些狗。由两种纯种狗混合在一起，并起一个可爱的合成词名字的杂交品种。这些狗通常被称为“设计师犬”，也许所有设计师犬中最臭名昭著的就是拉布拉多贵宾犬。
And that dog is what we consider to be the very first designer dog. But the guy who created the first Labritudele wonders whether he bred a designer dog or a disaster. So in 1989, a man named Wally Conrin was a breeder with a guide dogs for the blind type organization in Australia. Wally was contacted by a woman in Hawaii who was looking for a guide dog.
那只狗就是我们认为的第一只设计师犬。但创造第一只拉布拉多贵宾犬的人想知道他繁育的是一只设计师犬还是一场灾难。1989年，一个叫沃利·康伦的人是澳大利亚一家导盲犬组织的繁育者。沃利接到了一位夏威夷女士的电话，她正在寻找一只导盲犬。
But she had a problem, which is that her husband was very allergic to the Labrador Retrievers that are commonly used and trained to be guide dogs. So Wally really wanted to solve this problem for the women, and his first thought was, I'll take puddles, which are known to be pretty low shedding, a little bit hypoallergenic. Breathe that to one of these Labrador Retrievers, and maybe I'll find a dog that has the right temperament to be a guide dog, but isn't going to trigger these allergies in the same way. So he finds these two dogs to breed. Three puppies come out of the litter.
但她有一个问题，那就是她的丈夫对通常用于训练导盲犬的拉布拉多寻回犬非常过敏。所以沃利真的很想为这位女士解决这个问题，他的第一个想法是，我会找贵宾犬，众所周知它们掉毛很少，有点低过敏性。把它们和这些拉布拉多寻回犬之一进行繁育，也许我会找到一只既有合适的导盲犬气质，又不会以同样方式引发过敏的狗。所以他找到了这两只狗进行繁育。这窝生出了三只幼犬。
He sends off hair samples from all of the dogs to Hawaii, and only one of them is actually not going to trigger this husband's allergies, so they get that puppy. But while I had a problem, two of the Labrador Poodle puppies weren't hypogenic, and he didn't know what to do with them. And despite the fact that the guide dogs program had a three to six month wait for guide dogs
他把所有狗的毛发样本寄到了夏威夷，结果只有一只实际上不会引发她丈夫的过敏，所以他们得到了那只幼犬。但沃利遇到了一个问题，另外两只拉布拉多贵宾犬幼犬并不低过敏，他不知道该拿它们怎么办。尽管导盲犬项目有三到六个月的等待期，
when he called people, and the less they were like, we're going to wait for one of your normal dogs. Thank you very much. And he was so frustrated by this that he went to their PR department and was like, look, just tell the media, we've bred a new special kind of dog. It's called a Labradordoodle. It was the exact same dog as the Labradordoodle crossbreed, just with a different name. It was a marketing gimmick that really got on.
当他打电话给人们时，他们却说，我们要等你的普通狗。非常感谢。他对此感到非常沮丧，以至于他去了他们的公关部门说，看，只要告诉媒体，我们繁育了一种新的特殊品种的狗。它叫拉布拉多贵宾犬。它和拉布拉多贵宾犬杂交品种完全一样，只是名字不同。这是一个真正火起来的营销噱头。
The name stuck and people started to go wild for these dogs. All of a sudden he started getting all of these calls. Well, he says he realized what he had done within a matter of days. He went to his boss and said, look, I've created a monster. We need to do something to control it. But they couldn't put a patent on the breed, and soon breeders from all over the world join in on the trend. They became so popular that like every other time a dog becomes,
名字传开了，人们开始为这些狗疯狂。突然之间，他开始接到所有这些电话。好吧，他说他在几天之内就意识到自己做了什么。他去找老板说，看，我创造了一个怪物。我们需要做点什么来控制它。但他们无法为这个品种申请专利，很快来自世界各地的繁育者都加入了这个潮流。它们变得如此受欢迎，以至于像每次狗成为
you know, the it dog, a lot of people started breeding these dogs together to make money. And then my friends as our designer dogs first came on the scene. That was 1989. Today, Wally Conran is retired and he deeply regrets breeding that first lab riddle. He says he feels like he quote, opened Pandora's box and quote, released a Frankenstein. That's because when a popular commodity collides with greed, things get ugly. In this case, it means a lot of these dogs aren't carefully bred, or that they're overbred, and they end up with a whole host of health issues. We had so much demand for dogs last year, in particular, that a lot of dogs have been
你知道，“流行犬”时一样，很多人开始把这些狗繁育在一起赚钱。然后我的朋友们，我们的设计师犬第一次出现在现场。那是1989年。今天，沃利·康伦已经退休，他深深后悔繁育了第一只拉布拉多贵宾犬。他说他感觉自己“打开了潘多拉魔盒”，释放了一个“弗兰肯斯坦”。这是因为当一种流行的商品与贪婪碰撞时，事情就会变得丑陋。在这种情况下，这意味着这些狗中的许多没有经过仔细繁育，或者它们被过度繁育，最终导致了一系列健康问题。去年我们对狗的需求如此之大，以至于很多狗
actually coming in from overseas and those are marketed as, you know, the same dog, you know, no one tells you that they're actually coming from the Ukraine and a lot of these dogs are removed from their mothers younger than they're supposed to be, you know, vaccination records are falsified. It's just any time you're turning a living animal into a commodity, and then that commodity becomes popular, there are just snowballing problems that are going to come from that. Of course, a lot of people,
实际上是从海外进来的，那些被营销为，你知道，同样的狗，你知道，没有人告诉你它们实际上来自乌克兰，而且这些狗中的许多在比它们应该离开母亲的时间更早的时候就被带走了，你知道，疫苗接种记录是伪造的。只要你把活的动物变成商品，然后这种商品变得流行，就会出现滚雪球般的问题。当然，很多人，
lab or at-doodle owners included, would disagree that their dogs are the equivalent to Frankenstein's monster, and it totally makes sense that they would. The individual dogs are probably great, and if they're overall not as healthy, so be it, your dog is great, and it has a cute name, how could you not love that? But the dilemma is exactly the same
包括拉布拉多贵宾犬的主人，会不同意他们的狗等同于弗兰肯斯坦的怪物，他们这样想完全合理。这些个体狗可能很棒，如果它们整体上不那么健康，那就这样吧，你的狗很棒，而且它有一个可爱的名字，你怎么能不爱它呢？但困境完全一样，
as it is for purebred dogs. They just have a catch your name. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Lashem Mdon and edited by Vivian Le. Mixed in Tech Production by Dara Hirsch, music by our director of Sound, Swan Rihau. Delaney Hall is the executive producer Kurt Colstad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Peruvé, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Tova Danevich, check out her article, The Very Cute, Totally Disturbing Tale of the American It Dog on Box and keep an eye out for Tova's fourth-coming book about chickens.
就像纯种狗一样。它们只是有一个更吸引人的名字。《99%隐形》本周由拉舍姆·姆登制作，薇薇安·勒编辑。技术制作由达拉·赫什负责，音乐由我们的声音总监斯旺·里豪创作。德莱尼·霍尔是执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。团队其他成员包括克里斯·佩鲁维、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、乔·罗森伯格、索菲亚·克拉茨克和我，罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢托娃·德诺维奇，请查看她在Vox上的文章《美国流行犬的可爱而令人不安的故事》，并留意托娃即将出版的关于鸡的书。
We are a part of the Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, In beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI or on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Okay, Kara. Light down. Good boy, Kara. Say, Stitcher.
我们现在是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI，或者在Instagram和Reddit上关注。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接以及《99%隐形》的每一集往期节目。好了，卡拉。躺下。好孩子，卡拉。说，Stitcher。
Good. Say, Series XM. Good boy. Good. Say, Siri sex him. Good boy. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好。说，Sirius XM。好孩子。好。说，Sirius XM。好孩子。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。